as if you already know how to do
multiplication it's going to be
basically the exact same technique so
you have eight point two times six now
what you're going to do is you're just
going to pretend like all the numbers
are just whole numbers that this decimal
is not even there just can pretend like
this is 82 times six okay so you're with
me so far so you just do six times two
is twelve so I put down the ones unit
and I carry the tens unit okay so 6
times 2 is 12 6 times 8 is 48 plus one
is 49 ok and that's it we've got it now
the only thing you have to do now is you
have to count how many decimal places
you know has the decimal been moved so
in this case you can see it's been moved
one place that's it so you take the
decimal which is here at the right side
or the end of the number and you move
that one place so the answer here is 49
point two ok let's look at another
example this one here we've got four
point five times two point seven now
just a quick note you don't have to line
up the decimal points you only do that
when you're adding and subtracting
decimals with multiplying you don't have
to line them up you're just gonna be
thinking of these numbers as two whole
numbers 45 times 27 okay so we've got 7
times 5 which is 35 so I put down the
ones unit and I carry the tens unit 7
times 4 is 28 plus 3 is 31 I put 0 for a
placeholder there 2 times 5 is 10 I put
down the ones unit carry the tens unit 2
times 4 is 8 plus the 1 is 9 and then I
just add straight down ok and now what
we do is we count the number of decimal
places so we say this has been moved
once this has been moved once that's one
plus 1 which is 2 so I'm going to move
this decimal point 2 places to the left
from the right side of the numbers so
the final answer is 12 point 1 5 so
you're getting how easy this is it's
really just like multiplying two whole
numbers and then County the number of
decimal places so you just kind of
ignore the decimal points so let's look
at one last example 9 point 8 times 0.2
one I'm just thinking in my mind this is
98 times 21 and it doesn't matter what
order you put these in whether you put
this one here this one here it doesn't
really matter so let's take a look at
how to approach this one we've got 1
times 8 is 8 1 times 9 is 9 I put 0
that's the placeholder here 2 times 8 is
tene I'm carrying the 1 2 times 9 is 18
plus 1 is 19 I'm adding straight down 9
plus 6 is 15 carry the 1 that's 10 carry
the 1
ok 2058 but it looks like the decimal
points been moved 1 2 3 places so I have
to move this 1 2 3 places it's two point
zero five eight so that's the final
answer so I hope this helps you to
understand how to work with decimals and
multiplying problems that have decimals
in them
subscribe to the channel check out some
of my other videos on Mario's math tutor
and youtube channel and I look forward
to seeing in the future videos I'll talk
to you soon